oh oh hi everybody
oh I was occurring if you're anything
okay with go do those stupid intro ever
done in my entire life that was the
dumbest thing I've ever done in my
entire life okay so we got some strange
do daddy symbols here for this weird guy
and these whatever the hell they mean
maybe there's some sort of upside-down
thing maybe they're numbers I have no
idea but either way I'm assuming that's
gonna be two another code that I need
but I don't know what to do with that
now so I'm gonna figure that out later
so anyway there's got to be something
else here that I need hello can you tell
me your secrets I've got this flat-head
screwdriver now that can do something I
don't know what I've still got this
chair here I just don't know what I need
to do with it so there must have been
some of the room out here that got
opened while I was in here is there any
other room that isn't opening I hear
that what is that I hear that I hear
something you guys hear something right
I'm not just going out of my mind I
actually hear something it's like a wind
rustling through this okay I know I know
you bastard [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] bastard
but whatever whatever I gonna call you
nice booty I'm gonna try to get in this
closet but you're talking let me are you
in the rope
I was gonna hide in there well fine then
whatever ruin my plans so anyway there's
got to be something here aha I shouldn't
wait there's nothing there that was
pointless is there something here on the
wall is there something here nope
there nothing wait maybe I haha there we
go
ah flatheads got it got it nailing it
nailing it now innit
and Mont Oh goddamnit
okay let's look at this oh I got that
symbol it's right here on a Chipotle
napkin what am I wait Han if I look at
it backwards in the webcam okay kinda
looks maybe whoa whoa oh oh maybe ah
wait no we got that I need to turn him a
different way that one on looks like
that one looks like a four maybe if it
was backwards and then 3 0 9 4 3 0 9
let's try it 0 fine
nope that was wrong ok so there's got to
be something with that code that tells
something about it okay so this is 5 bar
this is really reaching by the way
there's five bars oh maybe the number of
lines in each character 1 2 3 4 wait 1 2
3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 4 5
ok that that would be 6 6 who's gonna
take me a while remember I'm incredibly
stupid so maybe I could blow the candle
out there'll be something there this
that for numbers is a tea in wait
brainwave
okay that guy's looking through bars
yeah I never get oh you didn't even
decide to follow me back to the way you
were too much of a baby to keep up with
me okay so anyway what was I doing
what was I saying oh yeah anyway I was
like I'm celebrating way too much
because you guys are probably like we
got that like on the first try it
doesn't take us two episodes to figure
that out whatever it's me we're talking
about here say what now what happened
where the hell am i I can barely see
can I use my lighter yeah it looks like
he's out of fluid it well that's not
good it's reality breaking down or
they're just some tiles missing on the
floor again where did this part of the
house come from anyway did it just like
magically appear found the item light
bulb well that's just fantastic what if
I needed it there I can barely see
things in the darkness here trying my
best spastically saving I like how I got
one HP one SP no experience that's
lovely
there's a fireplace
good ok ok this seems strange what's
going on here it's a little too quiet
just a little too quiet what was that
oh there we go ok so let's see here
there's a box white piece of paper with
nothing on it
I can move this box over over over and
drop it in the hole
there we go got that lighter fluid yes
all right good
sweet mega awesome bro you did it you're
the winner in my mind I wasn't even
using that much how did it run out of
lighter fluid already ok got lighter
fluid which means I can turn this on
nope still gonna be dark maybe I need to
burn that later no light bulb no plate
chard clay chard no there's got to be
something to do with that but I think we
need lights on in the house before
that's going to happen so I've got
lighter fluid what I can do with that I
have no idea anything out the window
it's raining very observant her ocean
good job what other amazing observations
can you make about this strange
predicament that you're in nothing cuz
you're a idiot good okay so it's dark in
here but now I can go around here oh hi
Takeshi how did you get back here it was
all locked haha Takeshi you're okay I
got your handkerchief it's spattered
with blood don't ask why it's a matter
of time till I get caught by that
monster there's nowhere to run if only i
if only I hadn't suggested we come here
we wouldn't be in this mess it's you
suggested the big bubble blowing baby
suggested what did you see a monster why
did you just run for really
okay all right then oh hello was that
for why did that happen why was that a
thing why was that a thing why did I
move that oh there's a little candle in
here like the candle yep okay maybe you
got scared by that statue and decided to
run away like a giant baby so what am I
doing here what am i doing with this am
I taking this with me I'm taking this
with me no one can stop me it's coming
with it's coming with me what's up here
oh hello there's more rooms back here
okay let me see if I can find someplace
to use this okay no that's not happening
that's not up why why why is that a
thing what okay I need to get one sense
right anytime I see a mannequin it
doesn't matter what
especially that [ __ ] right there I get
chills down my spine it's unconscious
it's just the way it is if I turn out
the lights and look at these guys are
they gonna be different
no thanks give me that Jamie Jamie's I
can't help it it's just unconscious I
can't take it I can't handle it
why what am i doing why am I looking at
you guys you were the freakiest frickin
cracker
Fricker's you have eyes you don't have
eyes you have eyes okay whatever I'm not
looking at those those are freaky as
hell I don't care go away oh look a
noose - which swift which - what what
did I just do I did something I didn't
mean to do it what did I did I did
something oh no I have royally screwed
this up
whoops ex okay let's try this again now
what I need to get the head into that
how I'm I was never good at these
pushing puzzles they they completely
lewd me okay no that's wrong I've done
it again how the hell are you supposed
to be able to do that that's just me
hi you have one red eye
I found the item door why did I take
that one why would I take that one here
is a noose with which to hang myself can
I hang the doll please I need a chair to
get up there oh my how is that supposed
to work that does not make any sense I
don't even think this one is possible is
it no idea I don't know I don't know if
this one's even possible doesn't seem
that way okay I'll deal with that later
I'll do that one later I got to figure
out the mystery of these dolls here doll
with one red eye what do I do with it
I'm confused I'm confused okay let's
move on to something else so won't open
screw I heard a thunk outside probably
people wondering why I'm screaming so
much probably oh my god okay anyway so
there's a hole in the ground here I can
drop down and go to this creepy ass
basement which is totally fantastic and
I'm so happy that I'm here and doing
this in this place so happy couldn't
believe how happy I am anyway um how
about this what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna push this thing over so that it
falls down maybe it'll break something
will come out of it that's a theory it's
probably correct
although boo-boom boo-boom and just oh I
can't oh no oh no oh no oh no oh good Oh
Oh worried for a second there okay so
that was not a theory that worked other
than that what do I do about this why do
I have a giant statue that I can push
can i push it up the stairs I highly
doubt that
no can I push it over here it's gotta be
something to do with this statue in
particular then I need to be able to do
aha you need to go this way I'm guessing
maybe I can hang this statue maybe
that's a thing why is it dark in here
did I leave this room dark hook there we
go hang yourself fool what am I going to
do with it what am I doing with it ah
piss okay what do I do with it
get over by this guy the chair half have
a seat over here in the chair No well
alright then I'll just have you stand
right under that noose for some strange
reason I don't know how to beat you
you're you seem like you'd be impossible
maybe there's other buttons that I can
press that would turn it around or what
oh whoops whoops okay sorry I
accidentally press some other buttons
are all right I don't know how that one
who's gonna be done but I I'm I want to
think I'm on the right track I don't
know if I'm on the right track I just
want to thank that it obviously didn't
need to go in here show what the hell
ah okay so I'm all out of time for now
or kind of so I'll figure this out one
in the next one so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video
baby
whoa did I forget the other one on the
other side I did didn't I
Oh nut bones can it still go oh yeah
that one all right then